MATTHEW MEHAN:
Welcome, everyone,
to the Allan P. Kirby Junior
Center for Constitutional
Studies and Citizenship.
And it's also the location
of Hillsdale and DC's
newly launched Steve and Amy
Van Andel Graduate School
of Government.
My name is Dr. Matthew Mehan.
I am the director
of academic programs
here at the Kirby Center.
And I teach both
the undergraduates
who come visit from the main
campus in Hillsdale, Michigan
and also in the grad
school, as well as
other more bureaucratic duties.
But I also get the
privilege of conducting
some of these book interviews.
So before I go any
further, I want
to introduce Richard K. Vedder.
He's a senior fellow at
the Independent Institute,
a distinguished emeritus
professor of economics
at Ohio University.
And I just met a
number of his students
who came all the way
out from there tonight.
So that's a great
honor for a teacher,
to have loyal students
who will travel.
That's great.
He has been senior economist at
the US Joint Economic Committee
and visiting fellow at
the Center for the Study
of American Business,
Washington University--
in my hometown, St. Louis.
Besides his most
recent book, Dr. Vedder
is also the author of
Going Broke by Degree,
Why College Costs Too Much.
His articles have appeared in
numerous scholarly journals,
The Wall Street Journal,
Christian Science Monitor,
National Review, Washington
Times, and Investor's Business
Daily.
And relevant to our purpose
tonight, and perhaps
also his most
impressive accolade,
Professor Vedder has been
a teacher for 55 years.
RICHARD VEDDER: Oh, 54
years, 55 years, something--
I lose count.
At my age, I can't
count very well.
But it's something
like that, yes.
MATTHEW MEHAN: Wise
and experienced.
He also has deep
roots in Illinois.
That makes him a
Midwesterner, thereby
earning him the title
to be held hereafter
in perpetuity of Good People.
RICHARD VEDDER:
Yes, that's right.
MATTHEW MEHAN: That's good.
I'm from St. Louis, my wife's
from Springfield, Illinois.
And for you Gen
Xers in the crowd,
I regret to inform
you that he is,
I believe, no relation
to Eddie Vedder,
lead singer of Pearl Jam.
RICHARD VEDDER: Absolutely none.
Never met the guy.
MATTHEW MEHAN: Even
though Eddie Vedder
is from Evanston, Illinois.
RICHARD VEDDER: The
school that I attended,
actually, is in that town.
MATTHEW MEHAN: And I will try
to use some references to lyrics
to Pearl Jam throughout
the interview.
But I'd like to thank
you, Dr. Vedder,
for writing this book,
Restoring the Promise, Higher
Education in America.
The Kirby Center here in DC, and
Hillsdale College in general,
we care a lot about
trying to build up
and enrich constitutional
self-government in our country.
And I was just teaching
the grad program--
the other day, we were going
through Aristotle's politics,
wherein Aristotle just
drops this bomb, oh,
by the way, if you actually care
about politics, statesmanship,
and leadership, your
fundamental concern
would obviously be the education
that perpetuates the regime.
It's just a startling drop.
And you've applied
much of your career
and now this book in particular
to taking up higher education,
where future educators
and future leaders
in pretty much all fields
are formed and informed.
That is to say, I'm very
happy to have this discussion
with you, especially
about this subject
because it's fundamental to
our concerns of the common good
and to the entire country
and to self-government.
So without any further
ado, and throat clearing,
I just want to ask you
to give us the bird's eye
view, the elevator pitch,
what is Restoring the Promise,
Higher Education in America?
What's the promise?
RICHARD VEDDER:
Well, I don't know
what the promise is because
I didn't pick the title.
Some marketing guru
picked the title,
and darned if I know
what the promise is.
[LAUGHTER]
However, having
said that, I think
the promise relates to the
fact that higher education is
to serve the common good
and is to serve society
in a very positive way.
And to some extent, it does
that, but in some extent,
it fails.
And so how can we make it
come closer to the ideal?
And I suspect the restoring
the promise refers to that.
But the reason I
wrote the book is
that there are several
problems with higher
education in America.
All of you know what they are.
I'll use my fingers here.
We don't have PowerPoint
here, which is--
I'm grateful for
that, by the way.
MATTHEW MEHAN: You and I
share an abiding hatred
for PowerPoint.
RICHARD VEDDER: I
hate PowerPoint.
I'll use what I call, and I
hope this doesn't offend anyone,
West Virginia PowerPoint.
I'll use my fingers.
[LAUGHTER]
MATTHEW MEHAN: He does
not speak for the college.
[LAUGHTER]
RICHARD VEDDER:
Hillsdale College
has already disowned you.
Dr. Vedder, do you
want to leave now?
No.
First, college is too expensive.
Everyone agrees with that.
There isn't a person
in America who
seriously disagrees with that.
Some people--
apologists for higher ed
will say, it's still
a good bargain,
you're still getting
your money's worth.
But the reality is the costs
in higher ed, however measured,
have risen vastly faster
than the rate of inflation,
et cetera for many,
many years, and I
can go into that in a minute.
But let's just do the short
and dirty version of this.
Now, the second thing
that has happened,
and this is more
scandalous and I
hesitate to say this in
front of my own students,
but let's face it,
people aren't learning
as much as they used to and
they're not learning enough,
and maybe they're
learning the wrong things.
There's all sorts of empirical
evidence, and some of it's
a little snippy, a
little limited because--
it's funny, in higher ed, we
are in the knowledge business.
We like to report every little
facet of every human endeavor.
But the one thing we're
a little neglectful on
is, do we measure whether our
kids are learning anything?
Are they doing better now than
they did a generation ago?
Do seniors know
more than freshmen?
Do the graduates of
Hillsdale College
learn more in their
four years at Hillsdale
than the graduates of Yale?
There's a Yale student in the
audience, I'll pick on Yale.
And my guess is the answer
is yes, but I can't prove it.
So there is an issue.
And with that is the whole
issue of suppression of ideas,
the lack of intellectual
diversity in universities,
and so forth.
So that's the second
area of problems.
Somewhere, I think in my--
I have a great quote
from, of all people,
Thomas Edison, who in 1921 told
The New York Times that, look,
I hire a lot of
college graduates,
and I think they're
abysmally ignorant.
That was in 1921.
Fast forward 100
years, and I think
they know less than the
people in 1921 knew.
So where are we?
The third problem-- and
then I'll keep quiet--
is, are the students
today, who are
spending $25,000, $50,000,
$100,000, $200,000 going
to college--
and some of them go to yuppie
private proprietary schools,
such as one that you teach at.
I'm picking on you.
MATTHEW MEHAN: Just a
huge field of yuppies.
RICHARD VEDDER: A
world of yuppies.
And do they get good
jobs after they graduate?
Some of them do.
Some of them do very well.
My students are all
uniformly brilliant
and they're all going to end up
making tons of money someday,
or if not tons of money,
tons of satisfaction.
That's not true.
Just look at them.
You can see.
But they're going to
do reasonably well.
But the reality is a lot
of kids go to college today
and they don't graduate.
Not at Hillsdale, where 90 some
percent of the kids graduate.
But at schools
around the country,
40% of the kids
who enter college
do not have degrees
six years later.
Not four years later, not five
years later, six years later,
they don't have college degrees.
So you lose 40%.
And then many of
the others who do
graduate are living in
their parents' basement.
So there's three problems.
And there are others
we can talk about,
but I've talked long enough.
Sorry.
MATTHEW MEHAN: No.
Yeah.
I wonder if we just
take each of these one
at a time for a little while.
RICHARD VEDDER: OK.
MATTHEW MEHAN: And when we do--
what I most want to know
is, who do I get to blame?
Is it the higher ed's problem?
Is it a societal change?
Is it a governmental change?
RICHARD VEDDER: Sure.
MATTHEW MEHAN: But
with regard to cost,
where do we point the
finger to find the problem?
RICHARD VEDDER: It's
a good question.
I assign a large
percentage of the blame
to, horrors of horrors,
the federal government,
the government of the
United States of America.
And to think that I'm saying
this within a stone's throw--
or a long stone's throw--
three blocks, four blocks--
at a younger age, I
could have thrown a stone
and hit the US
Capital from here.
But--
MATTHEW MEHAN: Again, he does
not speak for the college.
RICHARD VEDDER: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
A large part of the problem
is a federal problem.
And I hear it's just
as simple as can be.
The federal government made
a nice decision, seemingly--
seemingly-- it wasn't
a nice decision--
50 years ago, we want to
increase access to higher ed.
We want to help low income
people go to college.
Sounds like a nice thing.
Well, 50 years ago, 10% of
recent college graduates
came from the bottom quarter
of the income distribution.
Let's call them poor people.
10%-- no, 12%.
Sorry, 12%.
I shouldn't have had that
glass of wine before I talked.
Now it's down to 10%--
it's down to 10%.
It's less today.
Higher ed is still largely for
middle class and upper class
people.
Not entirely, but still largely.
But we put this in
to help poor people.
What did it do?
What did the colleges
do when they said,
oh, kids can borrow money up
to the cost of attendance?
So what did the colleges do?
They started raising their
fees aggressively, except--
and I'm really
serious about this--
except Hillsdale College
and a few others, a very,
very, very, very few others.
So here's a little factoid.
Before 1978, going back to 1840,
138 years of American history,
the price of college
rose 1% a year,
more than the overall
inflation rate.
And that might be explained
by some of the arguments
that people use today, that
it's a service industry,
it's hard to substitute
professors in a classroom
with machines, those
kind of arguments.
And a gentleman in the audience
is shaking his head no,
and he's right about that, too.
But for the moment, let's
just buy that argument.
That might explain a little
because as the economy
of the whole nation
got better and richer,
we had to pay professors more.
And even though they weren't
teaching anymore students
than before, we still
had to pay them more.
So the per student
cost rose a little.
Maybe that would explain the 1%.
Since 1978, fees have
gone up 3% a year.
Not 1% a year, 3% a year.
You say, no big deal.
Do a compounding.
3% a year compounded
doubles every 24 years.
Over a course of less than
half a century, it quadruples.
Tuition fees have tripled,
adjusting for inflation,
since the late '70s.
A large part of that is due
to the government involvement.
Bill Bennett said it perfectly.
He was the former
Secretary of Education.
By the way, a philosophy
graduate of Williams College,
trained in classical training.
Bill Bennett said this in 1978
in a New York Times op ed,
and it's true today.
So no great revelation.
So the student loan program
and the federal government
generally-- and I could
elaborate on this.
I could tell you rich
stories about the Department
of Education and its creation.
Let me tell real quick.
This is just too
good to pass up.
In 1976, Jimmy
Carter was elected
president of the United States.
He promised a
Department of Education.
Well, why did he promise
a Department of Education?
Was anyone clamoring for
Yes, the National
Education Association, NEA,
the teacher's unions.
He didn't do anything
for two years.
Jimmy is a little
slow sometimes.
Nice man, by the way.
I met Jimmy Carter.
My wife and I had drinks
and ate with Jimmy Carter.
We try to eat dinner with all
kinds of different people,
and Jimmy was one of them.
In '79, Jimmy Carter--
Hamilton Jordan, his chief
of staff, said, Jimmy--
President Carter,
probably-- President Carter,
you have to deliver on a
Department of Education.
And Carter said, why?
Well, the NEA wants it.
OK.
What was the reaction
of the general public
when Carter said I'm going for
the Department of Education?
What did The
Washington Post say?
It's a dumb idea.
The Washington Post!
What did The New York Times say?
We're against it.
The New York Times
was against it.
What did the most
respected intellectual
of the era on the
progressive side say?
Daniel Patrick Moynihan.
It's a dumb idea.
It passed in the House
of Representatives
in the Education
Committee by three votes.
Barely made it through Congress,
but they approved it anyway.
Narrowly got through
and became law.
What's the department
done since?
Is higher ed better off
than it was 50 years ago?
Is public education-- K
through 12 education better off
than it was 50 years ago?
Are we as a nation
have progressed
in this four decades?
I look at the data, I
look at the evidence--
and by the way, I've been
on a public school board--
an elected public official on
public school boards at the K
through 12 level.
I've looked at it
throughout the whole thing.
I don't see an iota
of improvement.
And I see, in some
ways, we're worse off.
We're paying more,
we're getting less,
and we're being directed by
bureaucrats and educrats who
live here in Washington
DC, when sometimes,
us people out in the boondocks
of wherever, flyover country--
I'm from flyover
country, I profess.
I'm not quite as smart
as some of you people
who live on the
east coast, where
knowledge is much greater,
or on the west coast,
where knowledge--
MATTHEW MEHAN: Beware
of the dsssssssssssssss
ssssssssssssssss
sssssssddddddddd
dddddddddddddddd
ddddddddddddddddddddddddddddd
speaker.
RICHARD VEDDER: I'm part
of the dumb middle part
of the country.
But some of those people in the
dumb middle part of the country
aren't quite as dumb as
you make it out to be.
And I think we're
doing all right, then.
Anyway, I'm sorry.
MATTHEW MEHAN: No.
RICHARD VEDDER: I'm
talking too much here.
MATTHEW MEHAN: But
it's a question
I have with regard to costs.
So the occasion
for this ramp up--
this exponential ramp up is the
federally-backed loans, right?
RICHARD VEDDER: Yes.
MATTHEW MEHAN: But don't
we still fault higher ed
for greedily grabbing at it
and saddling all these students
with--
RICHARD VEDDER: Well, the higher
ed of course grabbed at it.
MATTHEW MEHAN: And what
about the families?
RICHARD VEDDER: Oh, yeah.
The families be damned.
Well, more or less.
And I will say there
are exceptions.
We're in the temples of
exceptions here at Hillsdale.
But Grove City College--
there are some other colleges
that have done similar
things and have said, just
say no to the federal programs.
So the federal programs
have been the basis for it.
A lot of colleges do it.
The people who run colleges,
they're decent people.
They're not all mean people.
They don't all beat
their wives or whatever.
They're morally-- they like to
say they're a little bit better
than the rest of us.
I don't know whether
they're better or worse,
but they're normal people.
And they're tempted--
they can say, hey,
we can raise our fees 6% a
year instead of 4% a year.
And if we do that, we can lower
teaching loads for the faculty.
If we do that, we can hire
42 more administrators
and we can get rid
of these people
who are yelling and screaming
about diversity and inclusion
who are giving us a hard time--
we can hire 42 more
diversity coordinators.
How many diversity
coordinators are there
at the University of Michigan?
How many?
Last I counted 93.
93.
27 of them making more
than $100,000 a year.
You're shocked.
I'm not.
I live in higher ed.
I see it all the time.
And I'm not picking
just on that field.
You do the same thing with
public relations specialists.
You do the same thing
with athletic programs.
across the board.
And it is an outrage.
My university, which is a
typical state university,
in the mid '70s, had
two faculty members
for every one administrator.
Now we have for every two
faculty members, 2 and 1/2
administrators.
More administrators and faculty.
In fact, I proposed to the
president of the university,
why don't you give every faculty
member their own administrator?
Reorganize the university.
We'll give every
faculty member a valet--
an administrative valet.
I think it'd be a cool idea.
Sorry.
MATTHEW MEHAN: That's good.
So is the proposed solution
for the federal loan program
do what Hillsdale has done,
get off of the crystal meth
that's driving everything?
RICHARD VEDDER: Yeah.
MATTHEW MEHAN: Or
are you proposing
get rid of the
legislation altogether,
that it has no public utility?
RICHARD VEDDER:
Well, I would love
to get rid of the
legislation, I really would.
But I used to work
for the Gang of 535.
It's across the street, roughly.
That is to say the US Congress.
I've worked there.
I know those people.
I've lived with those people.
Have I said enough?
They're not going to do
it, and I don't blame them.
From a job security
point of view,
most Americans think
it's a cool program,
and you don't want to get
rid of something that's cool.
So what is the solution?
Well, one group of Americans--
and I don't want to
tie it specifically
to political parties, but
in this current environment,
we see it especially among
progressive Democrats,
Elizabeth Warren,
Bernie Sanders.
But now pretty much
all of them say,
let's just forgive the debt.
Why don't we just
say, forgive the debt?
What the heck?
We just let a--
what's another trillion
dollars or $2 trillion?
We're running, by the way,
every day $3 billion deficit,
the federal
government every day.
Do the math. $125 million an
hour, $2 million a minute.
Do the math further. $30
some thousand a second.
In the time it took me
to say that, we ran up
another half million
dollars of debt.
And here we are in
this environment
of total political
irresponsibility
in both parties, Republican,
Democrat, vegetarian,
Presbyterian, whatever
political party you belong to,
and we're talking
about forgiving
a trillion dollars
worth of debt--
a trillion and a half dollars.
We're going to
tell people who've
worked hard their lives
paying off that debt,
we're going to say,
yo, you were suckers.
You were suckers.
Haha, you actually believed
the government, didn't you?
Tough.
But the other people
who bought second homes
or took out big mortgages
and took trips to Europe
and so forth didn't
pay down their debt,
you don't owe anymore.
Free at last.
I think that shameful.
What do you think that
does to future obligations?
What do you think it
tells Americans in terms
of meeting their obligation?
What does it say about meeting
the sanctity of contracts?
What does it say
about the rule of law?
It is horrible.
It's horrible,
horrible, horrible.
I think I've made
that clear, didn't I?
So I'll be quiet.
MATTHEW MEHAN: So I wonder.
You have this other
question, sort
of the problem of the content.
A family's willingness
to take on debt,
it's an evaluation of the
relative worth of the degree.
RICHARD VEDDER:
Yeah, that's right.
MATTHEW MEHAN: Right.
And I wonder if the problem
would be alleviated somewhat
if the American
people-- families,
parents high school students--
were better at appraising
the relative value.
RICHARD VEDDER: That is true.
There's one thing--
I've been condemning
the government.
I suppose I should
be at least halfway
nice to the government for
maybe seven or eight seconds.
Today, the federal
government announced
that they in their
college scorecard, which
is a document where you
can download information
college by college, they report
the alleged average earnings
of graduates by college.
And now they're giving you
the data even my major.
So you could look at--
you can't look at Hillsdale
because Hillsdale is verboten.
They're out of the system.
Hillsdale is not in because
they refuse to kowtow
to the federal government.
But most schools you can look--
for example, at my university
I looked up economics majors,
and I learned that the average
earnings after graduation
was $30,000.
And I said, my gosh, that
strikes me as awfully low.
And I learned that the
average debt of students
is $25,000 upon graduation.
That statistic is probably
fairly close to accurate.
So that's a nice statistic.
And you could do this
for any college anywhere.
The young lady who's sitting
in the fourth row from Yale
but who is still looking
for a job, that's
probably $72,000 at Yale.
And their debt is less
because Yale drops money
out airplanes over
their students
because they got a $25,
$30 billion endowment.
But you get that statistic,
and that's good information.
So the federal government
has the potential
of providing information.
Turns out, there's only 47 Ohio
University economics graduates
in the sample.
When there are hundreds
and thousands of these,
only 47 made the sample.
And then it turns out, oh,
you don't get in the sample
unless you had borrowed money
from the federal government
to begin with.
Well, there are a lot of
people who don't borrow money
from the federal government.
So the data is vastly distorted,
just horrendously distorted.
But it's an attempt.
The attempt is a good one.
And I've talked to
Secretary DeVos,
who I think is an
honorable person
from the state of Michigan.
I see the Van Andel name on
this very building, associates
of the DeVos family from
Grand Rapids, Michigan.
Wonderful family,
wonderful people.
But I love Betsy DeVos.
But I wish they would
close her operation down,
and maybe it's time to let
the Georgetown University ROTC
have a bombing practice over
Maryland Avenue in Washington,
where the Department of
Education is located.
Anyway--
MATTHEW MEHAN: Again, he does
not speak for the college.
[LAUGHTER]
Yes.
So barring airstrikes,
the last time
I heard a candidate
credibly call
for the destruction of the
Department of Ed was Bob Dole.
RICHARD VEDDER: Yeah.
MATTHEW MEHAN: It was
part of his loud platform,
was the big push.
RICHARD VEDDER: How
old is Bob Dole now?
142?
143?
Yeah.
MATTHEW MEHAN: One of the
things I found very interesting
about your book is
you deeply ensconced
in the economics of higher ed.
Who's paying for what?
Where's the government funding?
What state schools versus
the Ivy League or the plucky
liberal arts college or
the citadel of reason
that is Hillsdale--
who's paying for what?
RICHARD VEDDER: Well,
that's a good question.
I can't answer the
question definitively,
but I would say that
there are a lot of people
who are seeking educational
attainment of some sort who
are really getting relatively
little from the federal
government.
What about the person who
graduates from high school who
is not academically terribly
interested in academic affairs
and not very adept
but is pretty good
with his hands or her
hands and wants to work
as a welder or a plumber?
It's going to take a
year or two of training
to make that happen.
Or take this very brainy,
high IQ kid who's good
at coding, whatever coding is--
something to do vaguely
with computers, I'm told--
and very good and they can
go to a coding academy,
and in six months, if
they're good, learn a lot,
and get a job paying $60,000
or $70,000 or $80,000 a year.
And the whole cost of the
coding academy experience
is $15,000 or $20,000.
Those people are
getting almost nothing
from the federal
government, almost nothing.
The kids who go-- and
I'm picking on Yale.
Yale is a nice school.
Some would say it's the
best in the Ivy Leagues,
and I sort of agree.
I kind of like Yale.
It's got that
yuppie, Harry Potter
look about it that's very nice.
I always thought
Harry Potter was
one of the most positive
recent contributions
to Western civilization.
Why are we giving
more to the kids that
go to Yale who come from
relatively well-to-do families
to begin with?
And not only what we
give to the kids--
MATTHEW MEHAN: But how
do we give to Yale?
RICHARD VEDDER:
Well, that's right.
How do we give to Yale?
I did a study once comparing
Princeton University--
the gal from Yale is having
heartburn back there,
so I will now pick on Princeton
for a minute, if I may.
Here's two schools--
a tail of two schools.
How far apart are they?
11 miles.
One of them is called Princeton
University, the other one,
until recently, was called
Trenton State University.
It is now called College
of New Jersey, which is
the original name of Princeton.
A brilliant marketing move
on their part, by the way.
Here are these two colleges.
We call Princeton
a private school.
We call the College of New
Jersey a public school.
How much money does the public
school, College of New Jersey,
get directly or indirectly?
Direct government subsidies,
grants to students, research,
whatever.
Maybe $3,000, $4,000
or $5,000 per student.
State of New Jersey adds
a couple thousand dollars.
Maybe $6,000, $7,000.
Let's exaggerate.
What does Princeton get?
Princeton gets the
advantages of tax deductions
against an income, which fund
a ton of things, donations
to buildings.
For example, there is
Whitman College at Princeton.
Any of you been to Princeton?
Whitman College at Princeton,
lovely, lovely place.
Named after Meg
Whitman, a minor figure
in American public finance--
of eBay fame, et cetera, et
cetera, whatever else she did.
She gave this little
college a little dorm
for the kids at Princeton.
350 kids live there.
It's got stained glass windows.
Ceiling in the dining
room is 34 feet high.
I had it measured.
I talked to people
in the-- what's
the newspaper at Princeton?
A great student newspaper there.
They checked this out for me.
The building cost $129 million
to build for 350 students.
This was a decade ago.
About $350,000 a student.
Meg Whitman got
zillions of dollars--
her tax burden was
reduced by millions.
And I have nothing
against Meg Whitman,
I have nothing
against Princeton.
So we gave a lot of
benefit to these people.
If you were a progressive
liberal Democrat,
I think the best
stand to take today
to be different than the people
that are running is to say,
I want to help the
poor, I want to do away
with federal programs,
I want to do away
with these programs that
are helping the rich,
the people that go to
The Heights School--
this is where he teaches.
I'm really being
mean to you now.
MATTHEW MEHAN: Any institutions
that anyone's involved with,
just make fun of it.
RICHARD VEDDER: Yeah.
Yeah.
No, I'm sorry.
I shouldn't.
That was beyond the pale.
I should not have said that.
And that's why I love Hillsdale.
I really do because
it has got principles.
MATTHEW MEHAN: But
again, what would be
the solution to this problem?
Is it an education problem?
People need to understand--
RICHARD VEDDER: Well,
there are ideas out there.
We're not going to change this
overnight, let's accept that.
So if you want to be
practical-- and let's
be politically
reasonable for a second.
There are some ideas out there
that would get at the problem
and start to do
something about it.
Do we really need to
give student loans
to people who are
in graduate school
for their eighth or ninth year
and getting an MBA at Harvard?
Could we put some limits on
the student loan program?
That's one approach,
put limits on.
Could we say--
let's make it clear
that people can go to college
and sell equity in themselves
rather than debt in themselves.
When a person goes to
college and takes out a loan,
they are, in effect--
there's an IOU involved here.
I owe you, the federal
government, $20,000 $30,000.
That's what it is.
It's a debt instrument.
Why don't they issue equity
interests in themselves?
Why don't they sell
stock in themselves?
I will give you 7% of my
earnings for the first five
years after I graduate if you
give me $50,000 for my college.
Income share agreements,
ISAs they're called.
They're not illegal.
But there is some
doubt in the law
whether they're
enforceable contracts.
And there are some who say, oh,
this is indentured servitude,
and they come up with purple
language to describe them.
I think they're perfectly
legitimate contractual
arrangements.
So there are some
things we could
do that would wean us away
from the student loan program
and involve the private
sector and, incidentally, get
the government out
of the business.
Because this can all be done--
JP Morgan Chase or Bank
of America or anyone
could do this, Rocket--
not Rocket Loans.
What is it called?
Anyway-- Quicken
Loans, whatever.
Someone could do this
in the private sector.
So there are alternatives
to what we're doing.
MATTHEW MEHAN: And
what about the--
we sort of touched on
it a little with regard
to people who are going
for non-higher ed routes
to their careers.
And there's a lot
of talk about that,
about coming up
with trade schools
and making sure that there's
not this notion that you're not
a real person if you don't get
the four year degree marker.
But what about their
careers afterward problem?
We haven't talked enough about
the third leg of the stool
in terms of part of
the higher ed crisis.
And what can we do to
better the reporting
that you were talking about?
RICHARD VEDDER: Well,
taking the first thing is--
I hate to say this in an
audience of college students
and college graduates, but
I think there are two--
we've overinvested in
higher ed in one sense.
We put too much money into
traditional four year degree
programs and too much
money into people
getting a diploma for the
sake of getting diploma.
And the government plays
a little role in this.
President Obama promised
we would have the highest
percentage of graduates.
We were slipping
behind other nations,
and we'll get back
to number one.
There are foundations
out there--
the Lumina Foundation from
Indianapolis is one and other
foundations who say, our
goal-- the Gates Foundation--
is to increase the percentage
of Americans with degrees.
So there is a mindless
push for people
to get four year degrees.
And we probably
ought to emphasize
more these other
alternatives than we have.
So that's part of what
we ought to be doing,
is putting more emphasis
on these other things.
And I think the
federal government is,
as I indicated earlier, a
large part of the problem,
but state governments
have contributed
to this, too, and others.
And well-meaning private people
have contributed to this.
I think the government ought
to get out of the higher ed
business in a perfect world.
But I'll accept
the fact that we're
going to have government
in the higher ed business
and say, how can we reform it?
And one way is to
privatize some parts of it,
like the lending
process, to reduce
the advantages associated with
this $130 million dormitories,
and you give them money
to a stadium project,
you get a tax deduction for
that so you can watch people
throw balls back and forth.
What's the public policy
reason why we subsidize
people throwing balls?
I have nothing against
throwing balls.
I kind of like to watch
football games once in a while,
basketball games even more.
But why do we
subsidize this stuff?
Why?
It makes zero sense
whatsoever, in my opinion.
MATTHEW MEHAN: Isn't
there something
on the moral plane of a basic
re-education about comfort?
When I think of my own-- and I
was in a dinosaur environment
that hadn't gotten
with the times.
It was sleepy and small.
My undergrad was one of
the last lousy cafeterias.
And I was going to
school in the '90s.
And then I went back and visited
there later on as an alum,
and it had become unbelievably
luxurious, just beautiful,
with 50 different parfait
stations and things like that.
And it was still
nothing compared to most
of the mainstream schools.
RICHARD VEDDER: No, that's
one of the problems.
There's-- I called it once in
a Wall Street Journal piece I
wrote the country
clubization of higher ed.
And there is that.
You've got to have--
these kids, they're
living in absolute poverty
because we don't have a
lazy river at our school.
You've got to have a lazy
river at your school.
MATTHEW MEHAN: You have to
explain what a lazy river is.
RICHARD VEDDER: A
lazy river is what we
used to call a swimming pool.
But instead of being 100 feet
long, it's 1,000 feet long,
and you can rent a little raft.
And if it's at a progressive
school that most of these are,
it has a little
place on the raft--
I've seen some of these,
an inner tube where there's
room for a cup to put your beer
in while you go down the river
and contemplate life
and get stoned or drunk,
or whatever kids do these days.
Why the heck should we
subsidize this kind of stuff?
So there is a lot of that
and fancy dorms and so on.
That's part of it.
Another manifestation of the
rising costs of higher ed
is an area I already mentioned,
administrative bloat.
And it's bad on a cost basis.
It costs a lot of money.
But what's worse is
it's crowding out
the academic function
of the university.
The academic function
is getting downgraded
by people who are functionaries,
I think the French might call
them, people who are doing
things that have nothing
to do with learning but a
lot to do with other things.
I mentioned diversity and
inclusion as an example,
but I could have
mentioned even fundraising
as an example,
where universities
are just overwhelmed
with administrators.
And there's a lot of
evidence for this.
Up the road, the greatest
argument for this
is a guy up at Hopkins in
Baltimore, Ben Ginsberg.
A great guy, Benjamin Ginsberg.
He's a professor of
political science.
He's probably politically left
of Elizabeth Warren for all
I know, but he says the
universities are being
destroyed by administrators.
We no longer make the decisions.
We're no longer in charge.
And whether the faculty
ought to be in charge
is a debatable issue.
I'm not sure they should
be totally in charge.
I am not sure I'd buy a used
car from the average faculty
member.
But they are doing what
universities are supposed
to do, they're creating
and disseminating
knowledge and ideals and virtue.
Virtue, by the way, has gone
by the wayside at most schools.
There are some exceptions,
but most schools.
We don't care about virtue.
MATTHEW MEHAN: Or
they've decided
to try a new idea
of what virtue is.
RICHARD VEDDER: Yeah.
MATTHEW MEHAN: Vigorously
trying to train everyone
in virtues that may not
actually be virtues.
RICHARD VEDDER: Yeah.
I think virtues that in the
sweep of Western civilization
over the last several
thousand years
would not be considered virtues.
MATTHEW MEHAN: So
before we open it up
to questions from the
audience-- and when we do,
we'll have microphones for you.
So just raise your hand and
I'll call on you one at a time.
I wanted to ask you to--
and this is Washington.
A lot of people
who actually really
care about trying to make the
doable change that touch off
the first snowflakes at
the top of the mountain,
they could start an
avalanche and actually get
something done to solve big
problems with little changes.
If you were talking to a
room of interested people
like this and donors
and politicians
and said, what are we all
going to rally around,
where do we put the
very tip of the spear
in, all of our
weight, what would you
choose as the one
thing to push on?
I know usually, solutions
are multi-valent
and you've got to do a lot.
But if you had to pick one,
what would it be and why?
RICHARD VEDDER: Well,
you're being nasty to me.
You're expecting me--
I'm good at criticizing
people, but solutions?
I'm a lowly college professor
in Appalachia eking out
a bare existence teaching.
As I said to begin with,
in a practical sense
and in a Washingtonian
sense looking at Washington,
I suspect the single
most important thing
that we could do would be to
work to downsize and change
the student loan program, which
would help with the cost side.
And the money that
those programs
raise through
higher tuition fees
pay for all these
administrators and lazy rivers
and a $17 million
football coach.
Well, they don't pay for
the football coaches.
Football coaches, by the
way, pay for themselves
at the really good schools.
I'm not saying
they're all virtuous.
Au contraire.
But that's what I would do.
I would work on getting
the government out
of the business of doing the
harm that they do the most.
And the most single harm
they do is in this area.
So can we let it go at that?
MATTHEW MEHAN: We'll have to.
Very good.
So questions?
Yes, please.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
for a fascinating talk.
I wanted to ask if this problem
that you've outlined here
isn't something that's
common in human affairs.
It's a lack of good governance.
And I'm wondering what
sort of structures
academic institutions could
adopt that would improve that.
In this very room
of a few weeks ago,
there was a presentation about
the problem at Oberlin College,
and it really sounds outrageous.
You can look at the corporate
world and look at the way
a corporate board of directors
works, but it seems to me
that alumni--
and people talk
about stockholders.
When you graduate, if you become
a shareholder in the university
or so, you have
a vested interest
in protecting the reputation
of your sheepskin or whatever.
It seems to me that
there are a lot of ways
to approach this problem.
Do you have any comment on that?
RICHARD VEDDER: Well, I think
university governance is
horrible the way it happens,
and that gets to your question.
Boards of trustees
at universities
are, I think, mostly
well-intended people
or truly interested in
their college and so forth.
But they're clueless about
2/3 of the bad things
that happen on campus.
I don't know the specifics of
the Oberlin College details,
but I'm sure that
the board of trustees
at Oberlin College, a
large majority of them
didn't have a clue
what was going
on at Gibson's
Bakery in Oberlin,
Ohio that has led to
embarrassment to Oberlin
and tens of millions of
dollars of potential damage
for them, hurt the college
greatly, led to some absolutely
grotesque behavior on the part
of administrators who should
have been, frankly, just fired.
And so in my--
I don't want to
keep trying to sell
my book because both people
that read it have liked it.
MATTHEW MEHAN: We will
be selling books--
RICHARD VEDDER: We
will be selling books
at a fairly reasonable price.
And I will leave an autograph
in them if you want,
which I doubt you will.
But there is a governance
issue in higher ed.
Who owns the university?
Who runs the universities?
Well, the faculty think they do.
They don't usually,
but they think they do.
And at some schools,
they have a lot of power.
Larry Summers, who is president
of Harvard University,
was Secretary of the Treasury,
he is Mr. Everything,
he got fired.
Who fired him?
The faculty.
He didn't like the notion that
women were as good at math
as men or something.
So that's a basis
for firing, I guess.
So the faculty don't
control the university.
The alumni think they
They give a lot of money.
At some schools they have
some clout, but at most places
they don't own the university.
The administration
probably has more claim
to own the university.
Who owns the universities?
No one knows.
Well, theoretically, it's the
board of trustees or the board
or governor.
In Virginia, it's the
board of visitors.
Who's on the board of visitors?
Someone the governor appoints
for a few years or someone,
in the case of private schools,
that's given a lot of money,
wants the prestige of the
name, goes to a meeting
about four times a year.
The president of the university
fills them with good wine
and drinks, gives them
tickets to the football games
and listens to the propaganda
that they feed the board, which
bares modest or no
resemblance to what's
really going on at the school.
And this is shameful.
But do I have an
easy solution for it?
No, but I think
that's one area I
would start looking
for some solutions.
MATTHEW MEHAN: It
sounds like you'd
want to get into the ear of a
governor and get them to take--
RICHARD VEDDER: Yeah.
By the way, I spent a year
on the Spellings Commission
on the Future of
Higher Education,
where I was supposed to
be part of a group of--
a blue ribbon
group, and it really
was a blue ribbon group of very
famous people, former cabinet
members, governors,
presidents of universities,
universities like Michigan
and MIT and so forth.
I was on this really
blue ribbon group.
Boy, we were going to
turn education around.
What did we do?
My wife was right from the
day once I agreed to be on it.
She says, you're not
going to do a damn thing.
She's more or less right.
Anyway, sorry.
MATTHEW MEHAN: Yes, there's
a question in the back there.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm one of the
Hillsdale students
here on the DC program.
RICHARD VEDDER: Wonderful.
AUDIENCE: And at
Hillsdale, we really
enjoy John Henry Newman and his
work, The Idea of a University.
And in that, Newman talks about
how the biggest contribution
a university makes
to the student
is teaching him
or her how to look
at the world as an
integrated whole, but also,
the mark that the university
leaves on each student.
And my question for you is,
how can we as college degree
holders go out and teach
people about this idea
and communicate it?
Because this really does
seem like the promise
of higher education
that's been lacking
in this post-industrial
post-modern world.
RICHARD VEDDER: It's
an excellent question.
I missed a little bit
of the part of it,
but I've read now Cardinal--
now St. Newman-- he's
been promoted to a Saint.
It's one of the
few areas of life
where you can die and 100
years later get promoted up.
The pope recently made
John Henry Newman a Saint.
One of the greatest,
wonderful pieces of things
I've ever read.
I wish every student
read it, and I
wish every member of the board
of trustees would read it.
We've lost sight of
the big things in life
and the important
things in life.
We've lost sight.
I just through the
word virtue out just
as a shorthand
version of talking
about the non-practical,
non-vocational dimensions
of higher education.
We've lost sight of them.
But I think our nation has lost
sight of a lot of the things
that used to be the glue
that brought us together
as a nation.
I'm getting a little
away from your question,
but the glue that
makes us Americans
is that we all have
some common thing
that we hold in common
that we believe in,
that we believe dear to us.
We're losing that.
First of all, kids aren't
even taking classes in history
anymore at most schools.
They don't know about
the Founding Fathers.
And I think that's shameful.
We need to move back to a core
curriculum, like Hillsdale
has done.
MATTHEW MEHAN: There's a group
of us wild-eyed reformers
who are trying to remind the
liberal arts colleges in higher
ed of their own tradition,
like to mistranslate
or re-translate artes liberales,
where that phrase liberal
arts came from, as the arts of
liberty just to shake it up.
Part of what you're trying
to teach is self-government,
and that's an interior thing
and an exterior political thing.
And that's, I think, been lost.
One more question.
I think we have time
for one more question.
RICHARD VEDDER:
Yes, in the back.
MATTHEW MEHAN: The pink shirt
over there, or the blue jacket,
whichever.
AUDIENCE: So I work at a
university, Catholic U,
and all the things
you said are true.
I've seen--
RICHARD VEDDER: Where
are you, Catholic U?
AUDIENCE: Sorry?
RICHARD VEDDER: What U?
AUDIENCE: Catholic University
up the road, about three miles.
You can see the dome--
the shrine from here.
I was reading about
endowments the other day
and the history of it,
and apparently they
go back to Greece.
There's [INAUDIBLE] Renaissance,
there's other nobles--
I don't know-- of
France, the state--
they were the state.
The nobles of government
subsidized education.
So it seems to me to be part of
the kingly power of a nation.
It seems to me a
human nature thing.
But you say we could do better.
Endowments are different than--
what is your thinking about--
this is already so much money--
we've been hitting on Yale.
Sorry, but there's
many endowments.
I was googling the other day.
There's so much.
What is you thinking about--
there's all that money
there that's in--
you always get news, oh, Yale
is buying land in California
with their endowment
to change the world.
RICHARD VEDDER: Yeah, yeah.
AUDIENCE: So sorry.
That was long.
RICHARD VEDDER:
Well, I did a piece--
I did some serious empirical
work on endowments.
First of all, Adam Smith had it
right in The Wealth of Nations,
when he noted that the
professors at Oxford University
no longer teach anything anymore
because the students are now--
because in an earlier
period, the faculty
got paid by the
students directly.
And when that
stopped, the faculty
didn't give a damn about
the students anymore.
The world went to hell, which is
probably a slight exaggeration,
but there is an
element of truth.
And what happened is
endowments insulate us
from having to pay any attention
to achieving excellence.
Why should we?
The money's coming in anyway.
And endowment money,
by the way, mostly
does not support lowering
costs to students.
I've done empirical
work on this.
I've run regression--
lots of economists,
we run regression equations.
I run tons of regression
equations on this.
The money doesn't go
to support students.
It does go to lower teaching
load for us faculty,
it does go to
increase salaries, it
does go to do a lot of
things that, really, I
don't think justify
contribution to colleges.
This is a terrible thing to
say here because I give money
to colleges.
I think colleges are
worthwhile endeavors.
I love my alma mater.
I love the school I teach at.
I love Hillsdale.
But some people have abused
that dimension of it as well.
So I'm not against endowments.
If I were, they will
not broadcast this
to the rest of the world because
Larry Arnn, who runs Hillsdale,
loves endowments,
and he should--
he should.
[LAUGHTER]
But in any case,
endowments are an issue
that need to be addressed.
AUDIENCE: Why aren't
they forced to use those
to lower the cost to
these attending schools,
when they've got $3
billion sitting there?
RICHARD VEDDER: Well,
there is an issue of what
should be done with endowments.
MATTHEW MEHAN: The
question was, why aren't
they forced to use them to--
RICHARD VEDDER: To lower costs.
Well, that is a good
empirical question.
I will say that when they put an
endowment tax in on very, very
large endowments--
I testified before the House of
Ways and Means Committee down
the road here before
the Gang of 535,
and I said there
is a case for them.
And I usually don't promote
higher taxes on anything.
But a tax on, I'll
say, Harvard, too--
our young lady in the fourth row
is already suffering enough--
a tax on Harvard probably
wouldn't hurt the world
and might help it a little bit.
MATTHEW MEHAN: Well, with that,
please join me in thank you.
Thank you, Dr. Vedder.
RICHARD VEDDER: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]